in wine there is truth in water there is
health I think therefore I
am through hardships to the
Stars remember that you will
die time
flies while I breathe I
hope the diee is
cast The Eagle does not catch
flies bread in
circuses
no one should be punished for their
thoughts truth begets
hatred don't poke the
bear fortune favors the
bold a healthy mind in a healthy
body make haste slow
lowly never
despair the voice of the people is the
voice of
God after this therefore because of
this there is no accounting for
Taste to live is to fight
from possibility to
reality nature does not make
leaps greatness from Small
Beginnings deep calls unto
deep to high places by narrow roads
I will either find a way or I will make
one one who has lived well has lived
unnoticed the blind are led by the
blind clear agreements good
friends work together to ACC accomplish
more believe that it is yours and you
will have
it it is cruler to be always afraid of
dying than to
die patience is the cure for all
suffering people condemn what they do
not
understand
tastes are not to be argued
with the law does not concern itself
with
Trifles he who has begun has the job
half
[Music]
done divide and
conquer teach in order to
learn
there is a middle course in all
things each man is the maker of his own
fortune Deeds not
words false in one thing false in
[Music]
all hunger is the best
sauce
resolutely indeed gentle in
manner Fortune is preparing friends
scarcity is testing
them the water drop drills through
[Music]
Stone history is the tutor of
Life man is a wolf to man
Desiring the same things and disliking
the same things this is what true
friendship
is to rule yourself is the ultimate
power in time of War laws are
silent in the land of the blind the
oneeyed man is
King
laws without morals are
useless One hand washes the
other cast not your pearls before the
swine the world wants to be deceived so
let
it nature is the greatest in the
smallest things
a shoe maker should not judge beyond the
shoe no one is a judge in his own
case there is nothing new Under the
Sun nothing but the best is good
enough not everything that shines is
[Music]
gold we learn not for school but for
Life Rome was not built in a
day observe
carefully there is no avarice without
penalty there is no great genius without
a shred thread of
insanity opportunity is offered with
difficulty lost with
ease opportunity makes a
thief everything that belongs to you you
carry with
[Music]
you money has no
smell a beard doesn't make a
philosopher better late than
never after Darkness
light first Do no
harm what hurts often
instructs how well you live makes a
difference
not how
long he who loves me loves my
dog he who has much desires
more what is natural cannot be
bad science has no enemies but the
[Music]
ignorant whoever desires is always
poor if it isn't broken don't fix
it if you want peace prepare for
war Simplicity is a feature of
Truth times are changing and we are
changing with
them
where one feels good there is one's
[Music]
Homeland a grape changes color in seeing
another
grape words move people examples draw
them truth never
perishes every hour wounds the last one
kills a fox may change its hair but not
its
tricks no one is Happy before their
death where there is Unity there is
Victory art is long life
short
Faith seeking
understanding spoken words Fly Away
written words
remain what nourishes me destroys
[Music]
me he conquers twice who conquers
himself no one gives what he doesn't
have
speak nothing but good of the
Dead a precipice in front wolves
behind Death is certain the hour is
not nature abhor a
vacuum agreements must be
kept
nothing happens without
effort where there is harmony there is
Victory clothes make the
man man proposes God
disposes it is good to be taught even by
an
enemy
take care of
yourself let Justice be done though the
heavens
fall virtue stands in the
middle for warned is
forearmed a name is a
sign while there is life there is hope
for the
[Music]
sick a healthy mind in a healthy
body in Necessary Things unity in
doubtful things freedom in all things
charity nothing without Divine
will the thing speaks for itself
time flies Love
Remains we gladly Feast on those who
would subdue
us what is allowed for Jupiter is not
allowed for an
ox to live is to
think time flies eyes like the
clouds he who is silent is assumed to
agree where there is the greater the
Lesser
yields bad times should be shunned good
times should be
sought without labor there is no
bread
love and do what you
will ignorance is not a
defense a true friend is recognized in
uncertain
times where there is honey there are
bees the truth will set you
free
everyone has their own
pleasure death is the final boundary of
things after the battle the
rewards remember to maintain a Calm Mind
in difficult circumstances
let the other side be
heard or is sweet to those who have
never experienced
it through difficulties to
honors if you want to be loved
love an avaricious mind is never
satisfied with
profit where there is doubt there is
freedom